merci Sonia de la pauvreté de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes élu du Calvados me
manque du groupe Union centriste on va
parler de la question de la pénurie de
médicaments dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est cette réforme
des retraites 740 000 manifestants selon
le ministère de l'Intérieur de millions
selon la CGT c'est moins que lors de la
précédente journée c'est un
essoufflement selon vous de la
mobilisation une baisse temporaire alors
d'abord comme on dit il y a comme à
chaque fois une telle différence de
chiffres que il est quand même un petit
peu compliqué de se prononcer
sur la baisse de mobilisation je
constate qu'elle est encore là et elle
est encore substantielle donc voilà pour
moi c'est ça le fait majeur regarde
aussi dans les sondages soutien pas
soutien de l'opinion publique quand on
est à quelques pourcentages dans un
sondage on peut considérer que pour
l'instant on reste avec un niveau haut
finalement de de
d'anti-réformes réforme des des
retraites la mobilisation est peut-être
moins de à Paris mais elle est elle est
présente dans dans plein d'autres villes
partout en France donc on voit bien que
voilà il reste quand même quelque chose
de
d'assez puissant et d'assez profond et
puis c'est compliqué pour les salariés
du privé de rester mobilisés longtemps
enfin voilà on a plein de raisons pour
lesquelles la violence aussi qui va
croissant qui est pas forcément un
élément de motivation d'une partie des
des
manifestants ce que je comprends tout à
fait justement on va voir ça tout de
suite du côté de chez vous à Caen
puisqu'il y a eu quelques incidents vous
allez nous en parler on va y aller à
quand retrouver Léa qui au bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous chefs
d'édition à la rédaction de Tendance
Ouest Léa quand fait partie des villes
où le mouvement de contestation compte
cette réforme des retraites et bien
suivi
oui bonjour à tous effectivement le
mouvement est très suivi à Caen et pour
revenir sur l'historique un petit peu de
ces mobilisations c'est notamment la
journée du 7 mars qui avait marqué le
coup à Caen et qui avait mobilisé le
plus de monde au même titre qu'au niveau
national d'ailleurs c'était l'une des
plus grosses manifestations si ce n'est
la plus suivie depuis le début du
mouvement on comptait 42
000 personnes dans les rues cannaises ce
jour-là selon les syndicats 24200 selon
les services de l'État une journée noire
et au-delà de la manifestation c'est
vraiment toute la ville et
l'agglomération qui avait été bloquée
très tôt le matin par différentes
actions de blocage sur l'agglomération
qui bloquait notamment les axes vers la
Bretagne mais aussi vers Paris et le
mouvement c'est ensuite apaisé les
samedis 11 et mercredi 15 mars mais on
peut pas parler d'essoufflement
bien au contraire puisque
le dernier le 23 mars à nouveau à 40000
personnes dans les rues ce qu'on a
remarqué c'est l'implication croissante
aussi des jeunes dans ces mouvements
cela avait commencé il y a une quinzaine
de jours au lycée Malherbe de Caen qui
est le plus grand lycée de la région des
lycéens avaient fait blocus depuis le
recours au 49-3 et ensuite on les a vu
on les a vu dans les dans les dans les
rues pour avoir échangé avec certains
élèves de terminale ils sont prêts à ne
rien lâcher malgré les épreuves du bac
et jusque les manifestations étaient
relativement relativement pacifiques et
calme et c'est seulement depuis la
semaine dernière que la colère a
commencé à faire quelques dégâts à Caen
vu une évolution lors des dernières
mobilisations
on a vraiment vu une évolution le ton
est vraiment monté lorsque la la loi a
définitivement été adoptée à l'Assemblée
c'est ce qui a fait déborder le vase à
Caen a commencé par la journée de grève
de jeudi dernier 40 000 personnes à
nouveau dans les rues et bien avant le
départ dans le cortège ou dans les
différents blocages on redoutait cette
augmentation de violence la colère est
montée entre manifestants et force de
l'ordre avec beaucoup plus de
dégradations que sur les précédents
rassemblements plusieurs scènes de
tension 9 personnes interpellées même
deux d'entre elles ont été condamnés à
de la prison et hier encore mobilisation
moindre pour l'acte 10 14000 personnes
selon la police mais des tensions qui
ont à nouveau éclaté en marge de la
manifestation avec des dégâts importants
sur la chaussée des feux de poubelles
des abris des abribus cassés et quelques
violences physiques je pense notamment à
une
automobiliste une femme qui a été
percutée par un automobiliste qui a
forcé le passage hier matin sur un point
de blocage la victime a d'ailleurs été
transférée à l'hôpital et entre force de
l'ordre et manifestants ça a une
nouvelle fois éclatée entre jet
projectiles et lancer de gaz lacrymogène
hier soir on comptait 13 personnes à
nouveau interpellé les manifestants ont
tout simplement pas l'impression d'être
vu par le gouvernement c'est ce qu'on
remarque au niveau national d'ailleurs
et donc effectivement tout le mouvement
est très très suivi à Caen et selon les
premiers retours que j'ai eu les
manifestants sont toujours très remontés
et restent déterminés à se faire
entendre c'est d'ailleurs ce qui va se
passer la semaine prochaine avec ce
rassemblement à Matignon vous avez une
question pour la sénatrice oui j'avais
une question pour madame de la propreté
puisque ce qui fait l'actualité chez
nous cette semaine c'est notamment le
carnaval étudiant de Caen qui se déroule
demain pour rappeler un petit peu le
carnaval de Caen est considéré comme le
plus grand carnaval étudiant d'Europe
c'est plus de 30 000 étudiants dans les
rues et niveau sécurité effectivement
c'est un gros dispositif de sécurité qui
met en place plus de 800 personnes ma
question pour Sonia de la pauvreté c'est
finalement vous avez été adjointe au
maire entre 2014 et 2017 vous pouvez
attester l'organisation du carnaval est
difficile est-ce que vous avez des
inquiétudes quant au bon déroulé du
carnaval demain dans ce contexte social
comment dire je ne lis pas dans le marc
de café et on peut pas dire que le
contexte soit très apaisé voilà pour
pour que on soit complètement tranquille
et rassuré
ce que je sais c'est que
des contacts ont été pris à la fois avec
l'organisation à la fois avec
l'encadrement
y compris
policier de secours pour que tout ça
soit renforcé donc c'est il y a un
renforcement de de l'accompagnement avec
un système de repérage rapide
au milieu de la foule des carnavaliers
parce que c'est vrai que voilà on attend
34000 personnes dans dans les rues rue
de Caen demain pour pour repérer
éventuellement des éléments
perturbateurs bon il faut savoir que ce
carnaval a aussi et et comment dire à la
fois un moment de liesse et de joie et à
un moment manifeste voilà de la jeunesse
et des étudiants donc bon moi pour
l'avoir
j'ai vécu des moments assez assez
particulier voilà et donc je sais que
l'important c'est que en fait le le
trajet soit bien conçu et il est depuis
plusieurs années et on sait que ça a
quand même permis beaucoup de pacifier
la présence des carnavalières et des
carnavaliers en ville et d'éviter
l'éparpillement de fin de de de parcours
et comme ce parcours est connu la
surveillance et du coup simplifiée et
que l'arrivée au parc exposition avec un
concert
va permettre j'allais dire de séparer
quelque part les étudiants qui sont
vraiment là pour s'amuser qui viennent
de partout en France voir d'Europe et
puis et puis d'autres qui profiteraient
de ce moment pour exprimer autre chose y
compris de façon violente ou inapproprie
vous êtes inquiète du climat social il y
a eu des violences hier je crois du côté
de Caen ça vous inquiète oui oui
évidemment c'est une inquiétude ce
climat social parce on a l'impression de
de revivre une espèce de de spirale
infernal comme on l'a vécu au moment des
gilets jaunes alors on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans le même concret contexte
là on est vraiment dans un contexte d'un
manifeste
politique j'allais dire presque plus
politisés quelque part les gilets jaunes
c'était vraiment le cri du cœur quoi et
la colère donc la colère avec toutes ses
formes sa violence etc là on est
vraiment
on est vraiment dans quelque chose de de
voilà à contre cette réforme des
retraites contre la méthode la façon un
peu la façon radicale courte pour un
élément important c'est deux ans de plus
quand même de passer devant
leur pivote de ce texte pourquoi alors
je me suis abstenue déranger voté contre
l'article 7 de 64 ans parce qu'on
n'avait pas fini de discuter le texte et
je me suis abstenu à la fin du texte
parce qu'on était préservés les inventés
les avancées sociales humaine j'allais
dire source d'une plus grande équité
même si on est bien loin du compte c'est
pour ça que je me suis abstenu et que je
n'ai pas voté pour parce que là vous
demandez est-ce que là vous demandez une
pause dans dans cette réforme voir le
retrait du texte
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
j'appelle un retour du dialogue parce
que là avec les syndicats et les
syndicats avaient fait le job c'est à
dire que ce fameux discours de voilà
un peu avec l'arrivée en 2017 du
président Macron reproche avait été fait
de voir une atomisation façon puzzle de
des corps intermédiaires et et
finalement les syndicats avaient repris
leur rôle
créant le vrai débat politique de fond
sans la violence et donc il me semblait
que c'était une bonne opportunité pour
redonner un peu de de
comment dire de politique au sens noble
du terme au débat en France et puis de
pacifier finalement la société française
tout le monde peut se prouver se
rassembler autour d'un débat sur les
retraites donc il y a eu un problème de
métades est-ce que là la médiation
proposée par Laurent Berger qui a été
très vite refusé par la voix d'Olivier
Vérand c'est la bonne solution est-ce
que le gouvernement a eu tort de fermer
la porte aussi vite oui alors on a
l'habitude de voir des portes fermées
qui seraient très très rapide à
quasiment aussi vite donc pour le coup
je je optimiste j'aurais pas d'avis
définitive sur le jeu des portes en
revanche je pense qu'une médiation est
importante ne serait-ce parce que la
violence monte en puissance de façon
très radicale un peu partout et que
la main tendue par les syndicats et la
main tendue par la première ministre
doit se conclure par une rencontre
réelle physique et un échange j'allais
dire peut-être un peu tonique mais ça et
utile on va remercier Léa Léa quineaux
qui était avec nous depuis quand merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous Léa 2 la
rédaction de Tendance Ouest on va passer
à l'actualité du Sénat l'actualité qui
vous concerne puisque vous présidez la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur la
pénurie de médicaments hier vous avez
additionné les représentants des
laboratoires et industries
pharmaceutiques on va voir les temps
forts de ces auditions avec notre
journal et Steve Jordan
[Musique]
bonjour madame messenatrices et Steve la
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments pour si donc ces auditions
hier ce sont les laboratoires et
entreprises pharmaceutiques qui étaient
en Tanger oui comment expliquer les
pénuries de médicaments qui touchent
actuellement la France c'est l'une des
questions posées depuis début février
par les sénateurs de la commission
d'enquête on rappelle quelques chiffres
au total environ 3000 molécules
n'étaient plus disponibles en France cet
hiver parmi elles le paracétamol et
l'amoxicilline un antibiotique prescrit
notamment pour les enfants la France
n'est pas le seul pays un concerné par
les pénuries mais les sénateurs veulent
savoir s'il y a un lien entre ces
défauts d'approvisionnement et les choix
opérés par l'industrie pharmaceutique
ces dernières années pour le syndicat de
l'industrie les causes des pénuries sont
multiples mais si l'on ne produit plus
certaines molécules en France c'est
notamment notamment parce que ça revient
trop cher à écouter
donner nous montre que nous avons un
écart de prix d'à peu près 37% par
rapport à l'Allemagne les médicaments
sont des produits à prix administrer et
nous n'avons pas la possibilité de
répercuter les augmentations de ses
coûts sur les produits à la différence
de la quasi-totalité des autres secteurs
le prix fabricant hors taxes de la boîte
d'amoxicilline c'est 76 centimes d'euros
76 centimes d'euros comment voulez-vous
garantir la production la relocaliser la
fortiori lorsque les coûts de production
expo c'est une vraie difficulté le prix
des médicaments il en a beaucoup été
question lors de l'audition les
industriels ont pointé du doigt le
mécanisme de fixation du prix des
produits en France écoutez votre
boulanger par exemple quand il décide il
a son cou d'électricité qui augmente il
a son coût de Safari qui augmente il a
le coût de ça de sa vendeuse qu'il
augmente il augmente sa baguette et ben
nous c'est pas possible
alors ça c'est pour le diagnostic que
nous partage pas forcément tous les
sénateurs peut-on inverser la tendance
et mettre un terme aux pénurie de
médicaments si l'on a délocalisé en
théorie on peut revenir en arrière et
rapatrier des entreprises sur le sol
français c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
objectifs à fixés par Emmanuel Macron en
matière de production de médicaments le
problème c'est que les professionnels
nous disent que cette relocalisation
n'est pas si simple que ça à réaliser
écoutez
vu le nombre de composants qui rentrent
dans la fabrication de de ces molécules
il n'est pas réaliste de penser qu'on va
pouvoir rapatrier toute la production de
tous ces produits la politique du
médicament est en train de craquer par
tous les bouts et il faut que la
représentation parlementaire en soit
consciente la politique du médicament
est en train de craquer madame la
sénatrice vous partagez ce diagnostic
oui en tout cas si elle est pas si ça ne
craque pas on est on est pas loin on est
quand même passé de à peu près 700
médicaments en pénurie à l'été 2018 à
quasiment 3000 donc on voit bien que là
on est à un moment assez crucial
ou
la logique de fonctionnement
international de la fabrication du
médicament
avec des monopoles par endroits sur
quelle personne n'a été vigilant enfin
faut dire les choses comme elles sont
quand on parle de l'amoxicilline par
exemple médicament essentiel enfin on
voit bien que quand il y en a plus il y
a un problème il suffit qu'il y ait une
épidémie quelque part ce qui se passe en
Chine par exemple avec la libéralisation
des uns et des autres et la circulation
très active de la covid et pauvres on a
besoin
d'amoxicilline ou enfin pas
d'amoxicilline mais d'antipyrétique par
exemple et donc
tout ça fait que c'est
c'est un vrai sujet
c'est l'objet de votre commission
d'encaisse quelles sont les causes pour
l'instant que vous tirez les conclusions
que vous tirez de première auditions
sont déjà identifiées par un rapport du
Sénat qui a eu lieu à l'été 2018 auquel
je participais donc c'était
utile de faire cette commission
d'enquête parce que j'allais dire mais
l'autre cran au-dessus et pour le coup
on se rend compte à quel point un
certain nombre des sujets n'a pas été
évoqué ce qui a avancé c'est l'Europe
voilà et et c'est clair que l'Europe
parce qu'il y a eu la covid et qui a eu
la question des vaccins qui l'a fallu
des commandes massives à montrer qu'il y
avait une capacité à faire des commandes
publiques dans l'intérêt de tous les
citoyens européens quel que soit le pays
concerné donc ça c'est ça c'est un
élément majeur c'est clair que là sont
des publics dans sa forme d'urgence et
devenue un élément qui peut concerner
l'Europe et derrière le pour lequel elle
peut agir mais dans dans les sujets la
fameuse liste des médicaments dit
essentiels elle n'existe toujours pas
ministre de la Santé vient d'annoncer
que on va la mettre en place
tout le monde serait bien inspiré de
considérer que déjà au niveau européen
ça serait bien qu'on ait une liste de
médicaments essentiels parce que au
moins la force de frappe de l'Europe et
quand même importantes pour pour en
terme de chiffre d'affaires pour les
laboratoires c'est pas la même chose que
uniquement la France donc qu'on est
quelques exceptions nous oui d'accord
mais que voilà est-ce que c'est une
crise qui est temporaire parce que là
vous parlez d'une pénurie de 3000
médicaments est-ce que c'est temporaire
ou est-ce que c'est durable il y a du
conjoncturel et du structurel ce qui est
durable enfin je pense que ça fait 15
ans qu'on la voit à les crescendo la
pénurie de certains médicaments on en
est même aux anticancéreux classique on
en fait pour tous les médicaments
matures qui ont fait leur preuve pour
lequel le prix est effectivement bas en
tout cas celui fixé en France du
remboursement on voit bien qu'il y a
voilà une pénurie parce que
conjoncturellement on a la triple
épidémie donc on a consommé et puis il y
a la co en Chine enfin voilà donc on a
surconsommé les mêmes médicaments et
donc il y en avait pas assez pour tout
le monde il y a eu un défaut
d'anticipation manifestement en matière
de fabrication parce que la dette
immunitaire par exemple on savait
qu'elle arriverait après la covid voilà
mais par exemple les corticoïdes en
gouttes pour les bébés qui font la
bronchiolite tous les hivers tous les
ondes à la même chose et ça fait déjà
5-6 ans qu'on a du mal à avoir des
corticoïdes
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
il y a des passions qui sont en danger
en France qui ne peuvent pas être
soignés faute de médicaments disponibles
c'est ça en fait le vrai sujet c'est que
il y a une perte de chance il y a des
retards thérapeutiques il y a des non
traitements il y a des il y a des il y a
des patients qui renoncent ils vont une
fois deux fois la pharmacie et puis il
renoncent parce qu'il y a pas de
lisibilité parce que même le pharmacien
ou la pharmacienne ne peut pas garantir
que le médicament va arriver dans un
délai qu'il peut donner précisément au
patients donc oui il y a des pertes de
champ c'est quand ce sont des
anticancéreux on peut dire qu'il y a
réellement des pertes de chance parce
que voilà les retards au traitement sont
forcément délétères et pénalisant sur le
plan de la santé publique et puis ça a
un coût ça un coup tout ça à parler vrai
les médicaments de substitution sont
plus chers quand on est obligé de
remplacer à l'hôpital on est plus sur
les appels d'offres classiques on est
obligé de négocier en B2B avec un
laboratoire qui évidemment
explose le prix parce que souvent c'est
ça qui se passe et ça coûte cher en
matière de santé publique parce que les
retard au traitement c'est plus de
complications plus de de symptômes à
prendre en charge et une aggravation des
pathologies toute pathologies plus
graves et plus cher à prendre en charge
de l'industrie pharmaceutique dans cette
situation il y a une alors ce que
j'allais
pour dire les choses il y a deux grands
responsables il y a les pouvoirs publics
voilà qui ont failli on peut le dire
voilà parce que ça veut pas c'est pas
les alertes sont là il y a des tonnes de
rapport etc etc et et je pense qu'il y a
des choses à faire et notamment
je vais pas vous donner toutes les
réponses du rapport qui n'est pas sortie
qui ne sortira qu'en juillet mais en
tout cas vu le nombre d'interlocuteurs
c'est cette question du prix du
médicament de l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché parce que je rappelle que
notre grand débat sur la santé tous les
ans c'est le projet de loi de finances
de la sécurité sociale donc on a la
porte d'entrée budgétaire le jour on
aura un vrai débat annuel sur la porte
d'entrée sanitaire à ce moment-là on
connaîtra le vrai coup de la santé et
peut-être le vrai coup du médicament en
France parce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait
tous les ans au regard de la masse
hôpital ville médicament dispositif
médicaux on dit oh là là ça va coûter
cher faut baisser de 5% parce que l'ONDA
m'a prévu que ou 2 % le Landa va prévu
que bon ben on va prendre la ville bah
c'est des gens qu'on soigne pas bon ben
on va prendre à l'hôpital et ben c'est
justement des intermits des intérimaires
qu'on peut pas prendre grand-chose bon
on va prendre les dispositifs médicaux
bas c'est quoi c'est des stent composent
pas c'est des prothèses de hanches qu'on
pose pas sur le médicament quand on
baisse l'enveloppe et ben on baisse
clairement il faut augmenter le prix des
médicaments est-ce qu'il faut dire aux
Français vous payez vos médicaments trop
peu cher il faut augmenter le prix des
médicaments l'Allemagne a augmenté le
prix de certains médicaments de 50% mais
la question se pose pour des médicaments
dit essentiels et quand le coup le coup
de revient
de fabrication et
à 30% au dessus du prix du remboursement
sur le marché on peut dire que ça c'est
pas tout à fait tout à fait normal alors
certes il y a les médicaments innovants
et certes on peut considérer que les
laboratoires ont un peu comment dire
c'est la course à l'innovation et si
possible très très cher bon voilà alors
je dis si possible c'est pas mais un des
objectifs de la course à l'innovation
c'est de mettre sur le marché des
médicaments qui évidemment rapportent
plus que des médicaments matures dont le
brevet est tombé et qu'on peut remplacer
par des génériques certes mais il faut
il faut quand même
se rendre compte que que tout ça c'est
un espèce de Tetris où les laboratoires
on leur rôle à jouer et le prix du
médicament qu'on a bien entendu ça
pleurait beaucoup la comparaison
hasardeuse avec la baguette parce que
enfin bon la santé c'est pas c'est pas
une un bien de tout ce qui est santé
n'est pas un bien de consommation
ordinaire donc voilà c'est quand même
nous qui payons tous c'est une solution
enfin l'augmentation du prix des
médicaments c'est une solution
et ça va devenir une nécessité mais de
façon modérée parce que ça peut pas être
une solution de de façon mais en Europe
ça c'est déjà fait dans plusieurs pays
et ça peut être une solution une fois
qu'on analyse des médicaments dit
essentiels alors essentiel ça veut dire
essentiel pour la santé mais aussi à
fort risque de tension et de pénurie et
puis les médicaments les laboratoires ou
aussi à alerter beaucoup plus en amont
sur des pénuries là il y a eu quelques
la NSM etc était intervenu parce que
quand on alerte deux jours avant la
pénurie sur un médicament majeur propose
un problème forcément de santé publique
et et un problème de responsable
et d'éthique d'éthique enfin je veux
dire on fabrique du médicament voilà on
fabrique pas les cartons pour mettre les
chaussures dedans donc donc il y a quand
même un vrai sujet éthique et à un
moment il faut que la santé ce soit
l'affaire de tous y compris de ce qui
fabrique mais aussi de ceux qui
structurent les politiques publiques et
que ce soit en France ou au niveau
européen il faut que ça avance
et que le filtre budgétaire soit pas
l'essentiel de la prise en charge
sanitaire en tout cas qu'on ne résume
pas tout à ça dans nos débats y compris
au Parlement de temps en temps oui
relocaliser c'est ce que c'est un des
objectifs fixé par Emmanuel Macron c'est
vous à l'échec ce qui est certain c'est
que
il me semble parce que là on a bien vu
quand il y a eu la crise de
l'amoxicilline les pharmaciens les 42
pharmaciens officinaux
qui qui ont pu fabriquer en France faire
les préparations en officines l'ont fait
et on pallier les carences que les
pharmacies centrales qui survivent
encore comme la gêne comme comme à Lyon
Marseille etc c'est pharmacies là elles
ont produit et dans les autres pays on
voit bien que par exemple au Pays-Bas on
en vient ces structuré une dans les
pharmacies des hôpitaux tout un réseau
pour fabriquer donc il faut qu'on puisse
fabriquer de toute façon de manière
publique en cas de très grosses urgences
parce que la souveraineté c'est
essentiel mais est-ce que la France
parce que Emmanuel Macron il a annoncé
ce plan de reconquête c'est en juin 2020
est-ce que on est quasiment trois ans
après est-ce que la France est à même
d'assurer sa souveraineté sanitaire
alors la France n'est pas à même
d'assurer sa souveraineté sanitaire à
tel point que on a eu tellement
d'annonces en janvier donc voilà ce que
je veux dire c'est que des plus sortis
plutôt sortis pas loin de la catastrophe
après la triple épidémie et que bon on a
bien vu que ça fallait pas et qu'il
fallait accélérer les choses bon après
entre ce qui est dit sur les plateaux et
puis la réalité il se passe un peu de
temps ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
reconstruit par qu'on construit pas une
usine de fabrication de médicaments en
un an deux ans il faut quand même un peu
de temps que on est peut-être assez
comment dire on est très fort pour les
normes que ce soit en Europe ou dans
notre pays où voilà on en rajoutait une
petite louche en plus à chaque fois donc
ça c'est une grosse contrainte parce que
voilà c'est du médicament ça se fabrique
pas comme ça
et ce qui est certain c'est que le
domaine où on a le plus perdu de
souveraineté c'est dans la partie chimie
c'est-à-dire fabrication des principes
actifs et des excipients parce que
j'allais dire on sait faire les composés
on sait faire les comprimés ou mettre
dans les ampoules etc
l'emballage carton c'est le fer les
blisters on sait faire mais il faut
qu'on retrouve plus d'autonomie alors si
ce n'est en France en tout cas au niveau
européen en matière de fabrication
chimique ça veut dire des savoir-faire
de la formation et remettre sur le
marché à la fois des techniciens et des
de l'encadrement et des chercheurs des
ingénieurs pour que voilà on est à
nouveau l'intelligence qui va avec le
avec merci beaucoup merci Sonia de la
pauvreté on suivra évidemment les
travaux de votre commission le rapport
c'est en juillet le rapport étant
juillet et on espère que vous viendrez
nous en parler merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec